les films les films les chine
les films
alors on va voir qu'une film audrey les
voir du pays on a choisi audrey et ben
en fait le fait très sincèrement
un film qui parle des soldats à leur
retour d'afghanistan ils ont en fait une
rame le mans dans un antre
un petit peu la cible ces deux femmes
qui souhaitent le milieu des touristes
et je crois qu'elles vont avoir du mal à
oublier la guerre c'est un très beau
film et la grille et réalisé par deux
femmes deux soeurs regardez qu'est ce
qu'on retrouve à l'est
ils sont là ils sont beaux ils sont
formidables alors si la petite équipe
enfin c'est notre équipe d'adoption j'ai
envie de dire est que nous rentrons dans
l'espace frangins oui alors il ya
d'avantagé moore
bonjour j'ai passé j'ai réussi l'examen
se contentant de regarder on est sur mon
team et des civils tout le long je sais
pas si j'aime être filmé mois combatif
d'ipl une caméra braquée
moi vous savez les caméras sa mort six
mois mais vraiment vous arriver mais ça
râle c'est sa valeur en rade
deux des films en compétition et ils me
disent les consignes par pays
francophones voilà et celui ci
représente
la france comprend d'écho encore une
grande encore une fois juliette va faire
des pas une miette
bon on se retrouve après le film bref et
comme ça on vous en reparle
je crois qu'on a besoin de décompresser
après ce film je pense que les
réalisateurs ont voulu nous transmettre
un certain malaise par rapport à la
violence d'une manière générale par
rapport à la guerre et en ça sert et
musique
on a pris une bonne claque quand même
c'est surtout c'est violent en tout cas
trois comédiens formidables
c'est un film intéressant continent doit
ça draine pas envie de rire la guerre
pour moi c'est un film qui met en
conflit voilà alors après vous en fait
quelle est cette phrase c'est le mieux
que je puisse
dire voilà